よろしくお願いします
えっと 東京タワーのエレベーターのケーブルが壊れたような感じで
今後エレベーターが下がるかもしれません
再来年からスカイツリーを建てます
で あの マリー先生の大変素晴らしい講演がありましてね
まあよく私たちにもいろいろいつでも参考にしたり
私たちもよくわからないところまでね
よく発見したりして 大変な素晴らしい仏教にはもう欠かせない研究を行っておりますので
それに比べたらまあケーブルが壊れたと思った方がいいと思います
エレベーターの はい 今日はウェーサーカ祭りですので
お釈迦様の祭りですね
お釈迦様をお祝いする
お祝いというか お釈迦様を礼拝するお祭りで
お釈迦様を紹介したいと思います
で 皆様はよくご存知ですからね
普通 お釈迦様の歴史はいくらかそれなりにはご存知だと思います
私たちはまあお釈迦様はね
なんかすごい方やとかね
いろいろ超能力を持っていて
神通力を持っていてね
まあすごいことをやったという
もうそういう奇跡的な人物として見たがりますが
お釈迦様はあんまりそういうことは気にしなかったんですね
で お釈迦様は本当に自分のすごいところっていうのは
この自分の心の状況であると
心が清らかであること
性格のことなんですね
ですから 今日はこのお釈迦様の紹介ということで
ある一つの経典をあのご紹介したい
これむちゃ長いんです
だからまあできるだけあの望みのスピードでいきます
で スッタニパータ・キッツにヘーマホータ・スッタという経典がございます
サーターギロという名前の夜叉がいたんですね
夜叉って鬼なんですけどね
日本語ではね ヘーマホータっていう名前のもう一人
また神霊がいて 同じこの人も夜叉というんですね
この二人の対話なんですね
その二人の名前はSとHに省略しています
S入ったら仏教徒のサーターギロさん
えーと Hが出てきたら
まあなんだったっけ？ヘーマホータさん
このヘーマホータという鬼がもうかなり疑い深くて
物事を調べるんですね
全くこの鵜呑みにはしたくない
で もう鬼なんですね 何でも調べて調べて
もうむちゃくちゃ もうそう簡単にははい
わかりましたと言わない性格なんですね
サーターギロさんがブッダに会ったことがありまして
この仏教を信仰しているんですね
だから友達なんですけど
結構なんでお前はという感じでいたかもしれません
この経典が あの えーと
とっても美しいんです
詩として しかし この文学的な味わうためには
原文をそのまま読み上げないと
それでもパーリ語がわからないと
またダメなんですね それでも普通のパーリ語の能力ではちょっと理解しにくい
ちょっとややこしい言語でもあります
私はまあむちゃくちゃ省略して
まあ一応いい加減な訳を行っています
最初の偈を読み上げます
で これ対話ですね この二人の
アッジャパンナラソーウポサトディッバラッティウパッティタアノーマナーマンサッラーランハンデパッサーマゴータマン
っていう意味はね 星が輝いて美しい満月の夜だと
で 偉大なる師匠ゴータマに会いましょうと
サーターギロさんが あの満月の夜は鬼たちが外へ出て
いろいろみんなに迷惑をかけたり
歩いたりする時ですから
今日は満月だからね 一般人は宗教を修行する日だからね
迷惑はかけられませんし
暇で何しましょうかと
じゃあブッダに会いましょうというふうに
サーターギロさんは案内する
そこでヘーマホータ鬼が
カッチマノースパニヒトサッダブーテスタディノカチッテーアニッテーチャーサンカッパッスワシーカタというふうに質問するんですね
彼は心を育てて清潔しているんですかね
いわゆるできてる人ですかね
こんなに我々せっかく会いたいと言ったってもね
性格できてますかと 一切の生命に対して冷静で揺らがないんですかと
鬼っていうのは人を脅したりして
もう人を殺したりもしますけどね
もうひどいことやってますけど
自分たちも結構怯えてるんですね
だから生命いろいろ差別を持ってるんですね
だからこの我々 せっかく会う人は一切生命に対してもう揺らがない
動揺しない 冷静でいられる人ですかね
とかね でなきゃ会いたくないよという感じなんです
良いことに悪いことに遭遇しても
彼の思考は制御されているんですかと
いわゆる我々人間にしたっても
やっぱり幸福はありますね
物事はうまくいったり
全くうまくいかなかったり
商売繁盛したり まるっきり何もうまくもう赤字ばっかしでとか
そういう波がある人生なんですね
これはどんな人間にもありますよ
鬼にもあります で 神々にもあります
うまくいったらうまくいかなかったりとかね
だから皆様はあまり気にしないでください
ちょこちょこっと時々人生さね
うまくいかない時もありますよ
ずっと好転するわけじゃないんで
そうすると面白くないんです
やっぱりとんでもないひどい目に遭ったりとかね
また立ち上がったりとかね
まあそういうことっていうのは
もう人生っていうのは面白いんです
で いつでも頑張れるんです
だからしかし 我々は頑張らないんですね
悪い ちょっとうまくいかなかった途端
ガクンと落ち込んだりする
うまくいっちゃうとすぐ舞い上がったりする
それだったら面白くないとこの鬼が思ってるんです
だからブッダがそういう好転しようか
もうもう順調であろうか
不調であろうか 冷静にいる人ですかと聞くんです
それで答えますね サーターギルさんが
マノキャスススパニートサッバブーテスタディノアトイッテーアニッテーチャーサンカッパスワシイカタ
心は制御されている 一切の生命に対して冷静で揺らがない
良いことに悪いことに遭遇しても
彼の思考は制御されている
ずっと冷静でいられるすごい人だとお釈迦様のことを紹介するんです
はい これからまあさっさと長いブッダの紹介ですから省略します
いつでもヘーマータが質問するんです
サータヒラが答えるんです
これからサータヒルさんの答えばっかし
まあ言葉せっこう同じですから
省略していたんです 与えてないものは取りましたと聞くんですね
それで取れない 生命に対して優しい
ブッダが本当に生命で優しいのか
ものすごく優しいんだよというのは不殺生のことですね
悪行為から離れている
離れていますかと聞いたら
離れていますよと 禅定に達しているんだと
あのパーリ経文読みます
ネスーアディンアンガーディヤティ
アトーパーネーシュサンニャトー
アトーアーラーパパマーダンハ
ブッドージャンジャーナンナリンチェティ
だからブッダっていうのは
パマーダンハっていうことを私ちょっと間違って訳したんですね
この悪行為ではなくて
不放逸ですね 放逸から離れるということで
ちょっと読み違いで間違えました
ブッダは不放逸であると
それからまた質問されて答えるんですね
嘘をつかない 言葉の誤りはない
これすごいことなんです
ブッダの言葉には誤りはないんです
これなんか違い 仲違いでしたっけ？仲違いの言葉はない
お釈迦様が二人がちょっとお互い仲悪いような言葉は絶対喋れません
人が仲良くなるような言葉以外は喋りません
で 考察の上で有意義な言葉のみを語る
ペラペラは喋れません
喋る場合はちゃんと考察した上で
内容が有意義であるものだけ喋るんです
だから私たちはこのパーリ聖典というのは
もうもうダイヤのようにすごい大事に守っているのは
もう勝手に誰にも編集させません
意訳したりはすることは認めません
ブッダには無駄話はないんだということ
すべて言葉には誤りはない
私たちに理解できなかった言葉があったならば
それは私たちの問題であって
ブッダの問題ではないという
この信頼がすごいんです
だから今も私はちょっと
まああの この一つ母音
短く読んでしまっちゃって悪になりましたからね
これは伸ばして読まなくちゃいけなかったんで
伸ばしたところで放逸になっちゃうんです
放逸はないと そういうふうにちょっとしたことで結構問題が起こるんです
はい 次は五欲に汚れない
心は澄んでいる 心はもうなんか澄んでいるって
この本当に深い湖のごとく
お釈迦様の心は綺麗に澄んでいる心なんです
はいと どこでしたっけ？一切の痴っていうのは無知ですね
やぶり 一切の法に目が覚めている覚者でありますと
ブッダには無知はないんです
すべてのことはもう発見しているんです
だからお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
今21世紀であっても
どんな科学発表によっても
何にも揺らぎません  2500年から我々我々は仏教のお坊さんたちがずっとそのまま仏教を語り続けているんです
改良はしません そのまま
しかし どんな時代でも見事に社会に適応できる先進的な教えなんです
だから 皆様の立場から見ても
時々私は言うことは この人すごい大胆なことを言い過ぎやと思っちゃうでしょうに
いえ 違います 大胆な革命的なことを私は余計に乱暴に言っているわけじゃなくて
仏教はそういうものなんです
いつでも社会よりは先に立っているんです
こっちだよと 道はと そういうことだから
このブッダの時代と比較するとね
今はもうむちゃくちゃ世界違いますでしょうに
科学発展というのはもう想像できませんだからね
私たちの時代を考えても
皆様どうか分かりませんだけど
私は最初に見た携帯はね
あれは結構肩が凝りますよ
運ぶ時は輪が一つ 1.5ぐらいなんですね
で これすごいベルトがあって
これ首にかけてリュックサックみたいな感じで運ばなくちゃいけなかったんですね
それも電話する時は外に行って
アンテナを伸ばして電話しなくちゃいけなかったんです
もうちょっと何年前なんでしょうね
今どうですかね 携帯は
iPhone になっちゃったりしてね
それからスマートフォンになったりして
でも目まぐるしく発展でしょうに
はい そういうふうに私たちももうものすごい発展
科学発展 進歩っていうのは見ているんですけど
ブッダの真理はそのまま変えられ変わらないんです
それより先にいるんで
いつでもお釈迦様が それはすごいことなんです
だからお釈迦様が目覚めた人なんです
真理を発見した人なんです
わかりやすく俗っぽく言えば
何でも知れなんです 知らないものないものなんです
それは仏教用語では ブッダには隠されていることはないんだよと
私たちにはすべて隠されているんですから
研究して発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし ブッダには何も隠されているものは何もないんだよということなんです
はい 次 これサータージラの答えなんですね
ヴィッジャーヤチェイバ
サンパンノ アトーサン
スッドチャリノ サッバス
アサワキナ ナッティ タッス
プナ バウ まあかなり省略は言ってます
知恵に達している 道徳実践は完了している
一切の煩悩が滅尽している
彼には再び生まれるということはありません
ということで で ここで何を言うのかというと
やっぱりもうブッダがもう全部性格的に得るべきものは全部完了しているんですね
知恵はもう完成している
それから人間としてやるべき行いやら実践やら全部完了している
だから完成者なんですね
何も欠点はない 欠けること何もない
これってすごくすごいことなんです
世界でブッダ以外にも宗教家がいるんです
イスラム教のムハンマドさんとかね
キリスト教のイエスさんとかね
いるでしょうに 人格はどうですかね
普通です むちゃくちゃです
で まあイスラム教の方いるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
ムハンマドさんの性格はね
もう常識ではね ちょっともう犯罪なんですけど
まあイエス様は犯罪を犯したことはないんですけど
で 罪を犯したことはないんですけど
性格がぐちゃぐちゃなんですね
突然興奮しちゃって暴れ回ったりするし
亡くなられた逮捕されたその前の日はむちゃくちゃ暴れなんだからね
あの大聖堂の前で束衣を繰り返したり
あれやこれやと 私はこれ壊してやるぞとか
あれやこれや 一般人がそんなこと言っちゃうとね
ちょっと頭おかしいってことになるでしょうよ
だからまあ それはそれで人間だからね
そんなにまあ気にすることないとは私は思いますけど
やっぱりそれでも人格としては欠点いろいろあるんですね
ブッダにはないんです
ブッダほど革命的なことを語った人もないんでしょうに
革命的なことを語ると反逆罪として捕まりますよ
ブッダは捕まることできなかったんです
で ブッダは隠れていたのかというと
隠れてもいない もう公でみんなの前でいつでもいる
王様たちと堂々と会ったりする
もうね そんなこと何のこともない
王様には言いたいことは言おう
で ちょこちょこと政治にも口を挟んだこともあったりもしましたし
しかし 誰もそれで何とも言わなかったんですね
人格完成しているんですよ
だから 当時のインドでも
仏教以外の人々でも 何か問題があったら
困ったことがあったら
あの釈迦釈尊に会いなさいという態度でしたからね
まあ困っているね まあ釈迦に聞けばという
仏教でない人々はね あまり尊敬しませんだからね
ゴータマに聞けば 答えるでしょうと
でも信仰違うでしょうにと
いや 関係ないんだと あの人はもうどんな人間にすぎたってもね
ものすごい優しいんだよと
宗教信仰とかそんなのもう気にもしない人やと
だから堂々と言って聞いてくださいと
そういうわけで このバラモン教の偉い方々も
エリートの方々も 自分の教えに疑問があったらブッダに聞くんですね
これどう解決すればいいかという
そういうふうな すごい完成者なんですね
はい えーと 何番でしたっけ？かなり進んだと思います
はい サンパンナンムニノチッタンカムナビャッパテーナチェ
ヴィッチャーチャラナサンパンナン
ダンマトーナンパサンサティ
五 行為ですね と みだらな道から離れた心は正しく完成している
では サンパンナ森のチッタンという
このまあこの赤い点は見えませんね
うちこのお釈迦様のお心はね
このお釈迦様と言ったけど
これ仙人ですね この仙人の心はサンパンナン
もう完璧に完了しているんだと
で カムナっていうのは
この言葉はですね これはこの行いですね
すべての行為はビャッパテーナで道から外れてないんですね
それからヴィッチャーチャラサンパンナとの三行目見なくなった
この三行目ね ヴィッチャーチャラサンパンナ
智慧と道徳が完成している人
これから四行目 ダンマトーナンパサンサティ
私はありのままに 現実に事実に証拠に従って賛嘆しているんだよとサーターキルさん言うんです
私はただ信仰でブッダの不安だから言ってるわけじゃないんだよと
ただ サーターキルさんがもう私はブッダのこと好きや
君も一緒に来いとは言ってないんだよと
私はしっかりと調べた上で
証拠に基づいてブッダを褒め称えているんだと
証拠に基づいて賛嘆している
はい それから これは大変有名な
学者の中では有名な偈なんですね
あの前の偈は四回 ちょっと言葉を変えて書いて書いて入ってます
エーニジャンガンキサンヴィーラン
アッパランアロールパン
ムニンワナスミンヤーヤンタン
エーヒタッサーマゴータマン
エーニジャンガン エーニっていうのはある鹿の種類なんですね
あの鹿のようなふくらはぎ
ふくらはぎが鹿のようって言ったら
まああの 格好はいいんだけど
細いんですね めちゃ細いんです
キサンヴィーラン ヴィーランっていうのは偉大なる人
ブッダが細かく細かったんです
痩せてたんです 今はこちら仏像あるでしょ
全然痩せてないんですね
これは仏像であって 仏像っていうのは
あのゴータマ・シッダッタという人物のレプリカではございません
だからあまり誤解しないでください
仏像を崇拝するとか何とかとかね
これが悟りの悟りを表現しているんです
完全たる解脱を表現しているんです
何も欠陥がない 欠点がない
完全であると 清らであると
だから仏像の目も人の顔を見てないんです
仏像を正しく目をつけたら開眼しておけば
どちらから見ても自分を見てないんです
面白い目の付け方なんですよ
だから角度から見れば
ちゃんと自分の目に合わせるようにと自分の体を動かせばいいでしょ
動かしても動かしても
お釈迦様は別な方を見ているんです
それでどういう意味？それがこの悟りの姿なんですね
世間とは一切の執着は切っているんです
だから仏像を見る私が世間の人代表なんですね
関係を持ってないんです
執着はないんです そういうふうにこの仏像を見て
お釈迦様はかなり体格のいい
丸々太っていた方やと思ったら
これは勘違いです 実際のお釈迦様が結構痩せぼっていたんです
手足がすごい細かったんです
痩せた体格がある 少食でほんのちょっとしか食べませんね
それにもあまり執着はない
あ これは美味しいとは言わない
ただ 食べるほんのちょっとの量は何でもいいんだから召し上がっちゃう
それ以上は食べません
それから森の中で禅定に入っている
私たちみたいにね まあテレビ見たりね
ワイドショー見たりとかね
時間無駄にはしないんです
で ずっと禅定に入ってるんですね
もう時間があったら 入っている勇者千人ゴートに会いましょう
サーターギルさんがずっと言うんですよ
もうあの芸４つも もうこれ5番目なんです
会いましょうよと言うんです
また言うんです シーハンウェーカチャランナーガンカーメスワナペンキナンウパサンカンマプッチャラマッチュウパーサッパモーチェナン
よく俗世間に期待がない
獅子のように一人で住む偉大なる方に会って
世の罠から抜ける道を伺いましょうと
この中でお釈迦様の性格は見えてくるんですね
あの獅子のようにしっかりと独立した精神で生きているんです
誰かの群れの一員ではないんですね
人間というのはいつでも群れの一員なんですよ
我々は人間はそれぞれ家族とかね
いろいろ組織を作って
その群れに隠れているんですね
釈尊が一人でいるんです
これ 比丘たちも出家比丘たちも
やっぱり一人で生活することはサンガ組織という先生も説明しましたけど
ありますけど 一人一人が独立することが大事なことなんです
独立したっても この組織から抜け出す
組織を壊すことではなくて
精神的独立なんですね
それは解脱というし 悟りとも言うし
だからこんなすごい方ですから
ブッダに会いましょうとサータギルさんが言うんですね
はい そこでまたスピードを上げて進みました
経典は これはだいたいあの２時間 ２
時間講演やると だいたい２回 ３
回程度やらないと終わらないぐらい長い経典ですけど
で 1時間以内で終わりにしようと思っているんです
はい そこでもヘーモータさんはまあいいでしょうと
そんなにすごい人であるならば会ってみましょうというふうに会うんですね
会ったら質問するのは誰ですかというと
ヘーモータさんですね
ヘーモータ鬼がもうあんまりもうなんか無神論者というか
もう信仰を持たない人というか
自由なんですね だから自由だから疑問するんです
例えば日本の社会で皆様はどちらかというと信仰を持ってる方々というよりは自由でしょうね
特別な何か信仰っていうのはね
日本の社会ではそんなにあるわけじゃないんです
あの800かける-4のあのカトリック教会あったっても
そんなに日本ではね あの
宗教を信仰している方っていうのは少ないし
だから自由な人であるならば
ビシビシと質問した方がいいんです
あの神父様が尊くて怖いとかね
あのお坊さんがもうやっぱりお坊さんだから
もう失礼に当たることをやってはいけないとか
そんな遠慮はいりません
もう聞きたいことはバリバリ聞いちゃえばいいんですね
だから平本さんはもうバリバリ質問するんです
これからむちゃ難しくなります
この世 世っていうのは一切の生命ですね
が なぜ起こるのか 世は何と付き合っているのか
世は何に囚われて悩んでいるのでしょうかという
これ むちゃ哲学的な質問ですよ
これ現代訳にします 生命はなぜ誕生したのかと
どのようにして誕生したのかと
生命は何によって生かされているのかと
生命の問題 何に引っかかって悩んでいるのかという
哲学でしょ いきなり聞くんです
あのキリスト教の聖書にしたっても
まあキリスト教という宗教はね
同じ問題でしょ 人間はどのように現れたのか
だから神が作ったんだそうと
じゃあ人間がどのように幸福を感じて楽しく生きていられるのかというと
それは神の恵みであるからですと
ではなんで人間がゴチャゴチャ苦しんでいるのか
それは原罪がありましたからと
最初に 天国というか 園で楽園で
最初に神が作った人間二人が神に逆らったという答えを出しています
だからお釈迦様にも同じ質問出されています
生命はなぜ誕生したのかと
で なんでこの言葉ややこしいかというと
生命は初めはなぜどのように誕生したかということは
もうインド哲学から見るとおかしい質問なんですね
鶏が先ですか 卵が先ですかと聞くことと同じだから
質問自体がバカバカらしいんですね
答えがないんですね そういう風に答えは論理的に直しているだけ
だから我々にはちょっとわかりにくいだけ
私は論理を崩してあげたらわかるでしょ
なぜ誕生したのか どうやって我々は生きていられるのか
我々の生きる上の問題は何なのかという質問三つなんです
で それのブッダ ブッダの言葉は
答えは六によって世は起こる
六と付き合っている 六に囚われて悩んでいる
わかったもんじゃないね
どうしますか？これ そのまま疑問として残して逃げようかなと思っていたんですけど
あとで説明が来るんです
で 今はまあ先に言います
大したことはない 生命の誕生っていうのは
この眼耳鼻舌身の感覚が生まれることなんですね
この感覚によって我はいると思っちゃうんです
だから感覚なかったらそこで生命も何もないんです
感覚というのは眼耳鼻舌身意の六なんです
そこでどうやって生きていられるのかと
何に引っかかって生きているのかというと感覚でしょ
我々は目で見たり 鼻で嗅いだり
耳で聞いたりすることが生きていることなんです
だから見られるもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 嗅ぐもの 触れるもの
なかったら死にます だから感覚六の対象
色声香味触法と言うんですね
それによって生きているんです
そこでトラブルはどんな時かというと
同じことですね 見るもので
聞くもので 食べるもので
喋ることでトラブっちゃうでしょうに
だから眼耳鼻舌身で生命が誕生して
眼耳鼻舌身の働きで生きていて
眼耳鼻舌身意のせいで引っかかって苦しんでいるんです
そこは六という言葉にまとめたんです
面白いことは 平本さんがそれをよくわかったんですよ
わかったんです だから次の質問はだから次なんですね
世はと囚われている執着とは何？どのようにして執着から離れる？苦しみからどのようにして自由になるのでしょうか？と
で 答え この世に五欲がありました
それから心は6番目です
眼耳鼻舌身意ということですね
いの対象 それらに対する愛着を捨てることで苦しみから自由になるのですと
すごい難しい答えかもしれませんよ
しかし ある面ですごいシンプルなんです
あの目に見えるもの 聞こえるもの
ありますね 花がありますて音があったりしてね
煩悩はどこにあるんですかね？私に目がありますし
私にこの花は見えるし
そこで煩悩が生まれるでしょ
この花は綺麗ですとかね
あの人は美人ですとかね
あの人は私のタイプやとかね
思っちゃうでしょ あれ煩悩なんですけど
だからヘーマさん聞くのはどうやって煩悩が生まれるのかと
そこでお釈迦様はすごい明確な答え出すんです
この体である眼耳鼻舌身意
六つ これはそのままありますよと
それから世の中には見えるもの
聞こえるもの 味わえるもの
触れるものがありますよと
心では考えるんだからね
概念 いろんなこと それで六つでしょうに
それはごく普通の生き方なんです
誰でも そこをどうすることもできないでしょうに
例えば私の目でいろんなものを見ると
欲が出て欲かけてどうしてもなくなっちゃったと
じゃあ私は目を何か薬でも入れて見えないようにする？嫌でしょう
例えば食べ物に目がなくて食っちゃうわ食っちゃうわ
それで病気になって太ったりして大変やと
煩悩でしょ 食べも食べるものに異常な執着っていうのは
じゃあその人の舌をね
取っちゃいますかね いくら何でもそれが嫌でしょうに
だから自分の体を壊したっても意味がないんです
あるいは見えるもの 聞こえるものを壊しても意味がないんで壊しませんしね
時々この苦行を語る人々が逃げるんですね
社会から 逃げて山に隠れて
動物の中で原始生活するんで
人と顔を合わせないとかね
中国でもインドでも 仙人たるものは人間には見えませんと思ってるんですね
人間の気配があるところは仙人がいないんだと
そこまで逃げてるんですね
しかしブッダが笑っちゃいますよ
逃げたってもね あなたはダメやと
隠れて動物の中でいたってもね
美しい鳥の声は聞こえるし
美しい澄んだ水があるし
美味しい果物とかね 手に入るし
どうするの あなたはと
あるいは険しい山だったらね
かなり厳しい環境で雪山だったら
そうすると気分が悪くなるし
風邪も引くでしょうしね
しかし薬はないし 肺炎にもなるでしょうに
それでも薬はなくて死んじゃっちゃいますね
それで人が見ても見ても
あの仙人は見えませんだからね
雪に埋もれてしまって
やっぱり仙人は人間に見えるわけじゃないんだぞと
またストーリーを作ったりするし
そこで未来になって見つかったら
いや さすが仙人でしたと
遺体はそのままありますからと
またストーリー作ったりするし
そういう世界にはブッダは笑っちゃいます
ここでブッダの答えが
愛着があるんだと 例えばこの花がきれいですよと
それでいいんです なんてきれいな花ですかと言っちゃうと愛着なんですね
私は好きや このタイプの花とかね
だからその微妙な差なんですよ
人に会ったら あ なかなかあなたは結構センスのいい美人ですねとかね
それ程度いいんです あんたすごいセンスが良くて美人だな
びっくりしましたなとか
私は大好きやとか あれがアウトなんです
あれでやられちゃいます
だから世間のことを評価しても
愛着は捨てないという
これが自分がやるものなんです
そこだけ直してくださいと
微妙でしょ？目を潰してくださいと言わない
見えるものから逃げなさいとも言ってないんです
普通にいなさいよ しかし
何を見ても冷静でいる
訓練しなさいと 愛着と怒りが生まれないように感情を取り消してくださいという
そのことが教えてあげたんです
難しいことなんですけど
ヘーマトさんがよくわかりましたね
これが この生命が解脱に達する方法とはこれなのです
それ以外ないんだと しんどいでしょうに
だから皆様にも今 お釈迦様のお教えを通してね
解脱に達する簡単な方法
すごい簡単です 目 耳 鼻
口 体とかありますね それにものを触れるでしょ
その時は楽しみやら苦しみやら生まれるでしょ
放っておいてください
愛着は作らない まあいいや
そんなことはと 冷静にいる
その訓練で悟りに達するんです
しかし 難しいところはあります
思考  6つですからね 思考は我々はすごい好きなんです
例えば 私はバカで 本当に何もできない
何やっても私はもう失敗ばっかりするんだとかね
みんなに嫌われてるんだ
私の私のこととか 妄想する人いるでしょ
あれ好きでやってるんです
あの悲観的な妄想は 自己嫌悪の妄想は
だからやめなさい これで病気になりますって言っても聞いてくれない
こんな暗い思考でね あなたには誰も仕事は与えてくれませんよと
で 聞いてくれない いえいえ
私のこと嫌いだから仕事をくれないんだと言うんです
だから私たちはこの美しいものはもうまあいいやと放っておく時も時々ありますよ
見たい映画はあるんだけど
まあ忙しいんだから まあいいや
やめますとかね 結構あります
私も時々見たい映画とかね
DVD とか買ったりしますし
時々派手に宣伝すると
その音楽でも CD でも買っちゃおうかなと買っちゃいますけど
ビニールシール貼ったまんまなんです
ほとんど開けてないんです
時々誰かが来たら これ恥ずかしいんだから
わざわざ開けてこれ見よ見よとかね
やるのは後で見ないんです
だからまあまあ見たい
聞きたいと思って買ったんだけど
まあ別にまあいいやということになったら見ないこともできますし
金はもったいないとも思わないしね
その時は欲しかったんだから買ったんであって
買ってからは嫌になっちゃったんだから放っておいたと
そういう品物はいくらでも私の部屋にはあります
店で見て気に入って買って
買ったままでシールも破れていないという
だからこの我々にはそういうところは管理できます
問題は思考なんですよ
思考は好きでやっています
なかなかそれに対する執着を捨てられないんですね
本当は瞑想しなくても悟るはずなんですけど
論理的には 思考どうするのかと
だから思考の管理という瞑想が別にそういうことで成り立ってますよ
皆様を意地悪取るために瞑想を教えているわけじゃないんです
わざとこの坊主たちがね
一般人が楽にいるのにね
あの ちょっともう迷惑かけようと思っているではないんじゃかと思って
瞑想しなさい 座禅組みなさいと言っているのではないかと
そういうことじゃないんです
我々の問題なんです 私たちは思考に
金よりも家よりも子供
自分の我が子よりも 自分の考え方に考えに執着しているんです
子供でもあの感動 感動でしたっけ？追い出すこととか
子供でも自分の考え方と一致しないと感動しちゃう
させちゃうんだよ お前感動やとかね
えらいこっちゃでしょ
自分が育てた子供のように
子供は独立して堂々と成長したのに
喜びはいいところは感動するんです
百年も続けているこの家の伝統はね
こいつは一日一代で壊させているのはすごいじゃん
独立精神がすごいと思えばとか言うべきところを感動と言うんでしょ
それは何のことなく 我が子よりも自分の思考に愛着があるんです
だから瞑想することになっちゃいます
で 解脱の道 ただそれだけなんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身から認識する場合は
愛着だけ作らないようにしてくださいと
これミャンマー版だからガッビルになってますけど
本当はバージョン違いでスリランカバージョンになるとガンビーラになると思います
ガンビーラパンヤンニプナットダッシンアキンチャナンカーマバヴェーアサッタンタンパッサタサッバディヴィッパムッタンディッピパティカママーナンマヘッシン
あのまた対話が続きました
今日はちょっと難しくなるんだからね
ちょこちょこと省略省略できましたけど
で ヘーマトさんとブッダがね
対話して ヘーマトさんがびっくりするんですね
この極極限的な真理を語られたんですね
教えたったんですね もうお手上げ
もう参りました ヘーマトさんがもう
人類が昔からこれからも探し求めている
この真理を何のことなく淡々と語られたんです
これで心を自由にする方法も本当に短い言葉で教えてあげたんですね
だから この神霊が二人で一緒になってブッダを讃嘆するんです
深遠な知恵 真理を明かす
何にも執着のない方 完全に解脱に達して天の道を歩む
この方を見よ だから ああ
すごい方がいましたよと
この天の道を この天というのは
まあまあ ちょっとパーリ語の単語で
この一般人よりはすごい優れた道を歩んでいるんだというね
別に 宇宙人星に行ったわけじゃないんです
次の日は アノーマ こちらないんです
アノーマナーマンニプナットダッシンパンニャーダダンカーマーレーアサッタンタンパッサタサッバヴィトゥンスネーダンアリーパティカママーナン
マヒーシン 偉大なる方
もう完璧に有意義なことを説く方
知っている方 智慧を与える方
俗世間には何のも執着
囚われることのない方
身をこの一切を知っている
この賢者をと言うんですね
それから聖者の道を歩む賢者を見よと
これは上に書いているところの
また今即興的な訳です
次 スディッタン ワタノアッジャ スッパバータン スフッティタン ヤン アダッサーナ サンブッダン オーガティンナ マナーセワン
これすごくいい芸ですよ
もう一回言います 自分が気に入ってるんだから
皆さんは迷惑でしょうね
スディッタン ワタノアッジャ スッパバータン スフッティタン ヤン アダッサーナ サンブッダン オーガティンナ マナーセワン
今思い出しましたけど
この同じこの木下お坊様がね
声がすごくきれいですよ
なかなかもう私たちのテーラワーダ協会の方に顔出しませんだからね
しょっちゅう顔出すってなれば
お互い話し合って もう木下さんがこのパーリ文を開けると
私は翻訳をするというふうにね
二人でやった方が良かったんじゃないかなと
で これすごい綺麗な節で唱えられる経典なんです
うん あのスディッタンというのは
スディッタン ワタノアッジャ
まあ日本語で言えば今日よかったと
ブッダに会って ああよかったよかったという単純
普通な表現なんです ただ
詩になっているんだから
ちょっと難しい表現になっているだけで
輪廻を乗り越えた相当学者に会えて
私たちのこの出会いは素晴らしいと
よくいい出会いでした
もうすごいすごいと 二人とも悟りに出しましたからね
良い光に照らされたと
それはこの スフッティタン
スッパバータン スフッティタンというのはね
これ辞書を引いて意味は取れない単語なんです
スッパバータンというのはグッドモーニングという意味なんです
でもその意味で取っちゃうと困ります
スフッティタンではよく雨が降ったという意味なんです
もうどうやって訳すればいいかとわからなくなるでしょうに
ではなくて ブッダのあの智慧の光
煩悩は全部煩悩という暗闇が全部なくなって
光というのは厳しくないでしょ？優しい光が照らしてくれて
照ってきて 自分の心にあった暗闇がさっと消えてきましたと
だからいい雨が降りましたと
智慧の雨 光の雨が降り降りましたと
いわゆるブッダの智慧という光の雨に降られましたよというふうにすればよかったんですけどね
言葉が長いんだからね
もうやめました ということは
ヘーモッドさんもあー
悟れましたっていう意味なんですね
神霊を発見しましたと
はい これで見事に終わります
はい えーと 神霊が帰するんですね
ブッダに イメー ダササター ヤッカー イッディマントー ヤサッシノー サッベータン サラナンヤンティー トワンノー サッター アヌッテロー
イメー ダササター ヤッカーイッディマントー ヤサッシノー サッベータン サラナンヤンティー トワン サッター アヌッテロー
イメー ダササター ヤッカー
あの二人が親分ですね
グループ会社ですね 鬼たちの心霊の
どれぐらいだっけ？ダササタですから
千 書いてないか えっ？千人の
あの心霊稼げる場合は人ですかね
わからないね 神社の場合は体ですね
体っていう まあもうどうでもいいんです
この千人の神霊たちはブッダに消えちまった
これ 神霊たちもすごい能力を持っている
かなりパワフルな神通力があるものなんですよ
何のことなくブッダに消えちまった
このブッダに消えたことを表現する
そこであなたは我々の偉大なる師でありますと
だから これは神に神を信仰して自分の自由をなくなる
意味じゃないんです 仏教の場合は
我々は自由を目指して仏教徒になるんです
何かに組織に入るということは
自分の自由を失うことなんです
しかし 仏教に入る人が自由
解放を目指して入るんです
それで三宝に帰依するということは
これから足足枷になるんじゃないかなんていうと
ならないんです ブッダが師匠なんですよ
先生です 別に先生は弟子を束縛されませんよ
道案内するだけ 卒業するまで
卒業するまでいいこと言うことを聞けなさいよと
反抗なことするなよと
それだけなんです それから卒業したら
あ よかったねと それで自由なんです
だからそこをこちらで表現しています
仏教徒になるということは
ブッダを師匠にすることなんです
私の先生は釈迦牟尼ブッダだよと
それだけ まあまあ 仏法僧も同じことですからね
次どうなったんですかね
仏教を広めることになるんです
テーマヤンウィチェリッサム ガーマーガーマンナガーナガン ナマッサマナーサンブッダンダンマッサチェスダンマター
テーマヤン ウィチェリッサム ガーマーガーマンナガーナガン ナマッサマナーサンブッダンダンマッサチェスダンマダン
はい という我々は まず私が訳します
という我々は これから村から村へ
町から町へと旅に出るんだと
という我々っていうのは
このサンキした我々千人ですね
何をしますかね 旅する場合は
どこに行ってもブッダには礼拝すると堂々と
それからブッダの教えこそ真実であると
それをみんなにわかるように礼拝して
ブッダを讃嘆しながらこれからの人生を歩むそうと決めたんですね
人生ですか 神性ですか
心霊わかりませんだけど
鬼性かもしれませんね
で これから自分の生涯はそういう風にやりますと伝道が始まりますね
だいたいブッダのことを勉強する人は
だいたい誰か誰かに何か自ら教えてあげたりはします
だから自分だけ救われればいいよという話が仏教ではないんですね
自分の心が安らぎになると
困っている人を見ていられないんですよ
あなたもこうやってください
あなたもこうやってくださいとかね
それぞれてきぱきとアドバイスする
で 時々私にももうでも無視されたとかね
親に怒られたという方々もいますよ
お父さんにブッダの仏教の本をあげたところで怒られましたと
どうすればいいんですかと
そこはもうちょっと勉強した方がいいんです
人の人権を侵害しないでね
じゃいけないんですね
悪口言ったってもグチャグチャ言ってもいいんだけど
人権だけを侵害してはいけません
いい例 日本の社会にありますよ
日本ではものすごいたくさんいますね
笑い芸人という方々はね
笑いのタレントさんたちが
また伝統もね 大阪のもあるし
京都にもあるし 東京にもそれなりの伝統があるし
それから現代的な笑いタレントさんもあるでしょうに
言ってることはむちゃくちゃ乱暴でしょうにね
気持ち悪いし アホでたまらないしね
でもみんな笑っちゃいますね
彼らが一つだけ大事に守るんですよ
このしんのすけさんでしたっけ？この明石家さんまさんとか口うるさいでしょ
平気で人をバカにするでしょ
しかし なんで笑いますかね
一つだけは 相手を人格を侵害することだけはしないんです
ちょっとからかって笑ってるだけで
その人お客様だからね
その人の人権侵害だけはしないんですね
だからそれなんですね
ポイントは だから笑い芸人のやり方をちょっと学べば
嫌にならないように嫌味を言うんですね
無茶嫌味言ってるのに嫌にならないという
で そこなんですね お釈迦様もすごく厳しい言葉を言うんだけど
聞いてる人は嫌にならないんですね
そういうことで 仏教に仏教を学んでいる人
仏教を実践する人が 誰でももっと人々の幸福のために
苦しみをなくすために
もっと自分の周りの人々に教えてあげることも
昔からのブッダの時代からも今まで伝わってくる習慣なんですね
お釈迦様が最初の弟子たちがね
60人現れましたね  60人も完全なる悟りに達しましたね
で すぐもう 60人もグループができたんだからね
それで落ち着いてもう楽にいるんじゃないんだよと
チャラとビッキーチャーリカン歩きなさいよと
あっちこっちで それからまあ永久のデーアガメって
二人組で行くなよと できればできる
インド広いんだからね
一人一人で歩きなさい
この幸福の教えをみんなに教えなさい
それでみんな上策はないかってわからないんですね
だから悟っても伝道上手な方も上手でない方もいますけど
それでも自分のできる範囲で人々にこの幸福の道を教えるということは
まあ伝統であって ブッダの時代からも今までもやっていることで
この鬼二人のブッダに会って説法を聞いて悟りに達した
あの瞬間で じゃあこれからも行くところで広げてやると
鬼だからもうかなり大胆に決めちゃったんです
うん だから 正統学者に教えが真実であることに礼拝しながら
我々は村から村へと 町から町へと旅をすることにします
ということで 今日の講演は終了すると思います
終了ですね はい どうもありがとうございます
えーまず最初ですね  30代の女性の方からの質問ですね
こういう質問です 私は気の強い人と一緒にいると緊張します
自分の意見などをすべて譲ってしまいます
このような自分を変えたいと思うのですが
具体的にどのようにすれば変えられますか？という質問です
うん まあいろいろありますよ
一番簡単な方に逃げることですけどね
で これはまあ論理的なだけで
一緒にいる場合 お互い話を話し合って
意見を交わし合って そういうコミュニケーションがあったならば
気持ちがいいんですよ
こちら言うことは向こうが聞くし
向こう言うことはこちら聞いてあげるし
これで二人三脚という感じで
社会では楽に生きていられますね
それでも気の強いというか
人の話を聞かない人々もいますよ
あれ 気が強いかどうかまた別なんです
人の話をあまり聞かないで
一方的に自分のことばっかり言う人っていうのは
かなり気が弱いんです
だからそこはかえって危ないですね
ちょこちょこっとでもそれに気づいちゃうと
またかえっても危ないんですね
そういう人々は 自分の気の気の弱さがね
あの あのあれで演じています
あの笑い芸人の中で爆笑問題というかなり能力のある優秀な二人がいるでしょ
太田さんがいますね めちゃ頭いいんですね
あの人は 信じられない笑い芸人でね
ある日テレビで彼の話を聞いていて
小さい時からもうあれやこれやとか考えたりしてね
もうもう暗くて 物事なんかなんかものすごく暗く見えちゃってね
いてもたってもなんかもうどうしようもない状態でしたと
今の頭がキーっと来るんだと
痛くて そこを直すために笑い芸人になっちゃったんです
だから笑い芸人としても大成功で
で 自分のあのガチャガチャガチャガチャ物事をもうきみ細かくうるさく考える能力もそのまま持っていって
だから太田総理というテレビ番組があるでしょ
面白いことは政治家が来るでしょ
政治家さえも彼の論理に負けるんです
昨日でしたっけ？石破さんをね
むちゃくちゃ倒して見せたんだから
あんた方は結局喋ってるだけでしょうにと
根本見てないでしょうにと
だからそんなことを笑い芸人が言っちゃうと
なんか変でしょうに しかし
彼がその能力を見事に上げちゃったんですね
そういうことで それでもう気の強い人と一緒にいる時でもね
まあなんとか適当に考えるしかないでしょうに
で 具体的にどうすればいいんですかね
まあ自分はまあこれが私が嫌ですからとかね
嫌なことははっきり言えばいいんですね
なんかこれこれやりましょう
ああ よくわかりました
でも私は忙しいんだからやりません
っていう感じにしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
何でもはいはいではどうしても人生は危険なんです
一人一人の人間にも人権があります
そこは自分が弱いかもしれませんし
相手がちょこっと強いかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり自分の人権も守るべきなんですね
だからまあ 笑っちゃえばどうですかね
あなた独裁者でね あなたはまあ2番目の何でしたっけ？フセインさんみたいなもんやとかね
あのエジプトのエジプトではないんですね
イラクのフセインが死んじゃったと話を聞いちゃったと
これ生まれ変わってるんだとかね
そういうふうになんとか何とか言うと
なんとかね 向こうも笑っちゃってね
あの人権侵害だけはしないでください
冗談に回せば人権侵害にはならないんですね
本当はこれ嫌なんですけど
このフセインさんの命令だからやってますよ
と言うと 向こうもなんとなくわかってくるんですね
そういうふうにやった方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい  ありがとうございます
次の質問です  30代の男性の方の質問です
仕事上などでの重い責任
プレッシャーに負けないための仏教の教えはどのようなものでしょうか
という質問  えーとですね
それは間違っています
重い責任はないんです
そちらに間違いがあるんです
仕事でいろいろやらなくちゃあかんのは当たり前でしょうに
仕事っていうのは どんな仕事にもある責任があるでしょうに
だから私も今日 あの先生の講演を聞きながらね
なんか仏教の組織はセブンイレブンに例えちゃったんだからね
で まあそれはすごい観察でね
まあ別にその通りだと思いますけど
で フランチャイズシステムで
私は考えたのは 私は何やと
もう私もそうするとテーラワーダ協会という店の棚整理する人でしょうかねとかね
もしかすると仕入れ担当かもしれませんとかね
転居にはしてくれませんよとかね
そういろいろ思ったりはしましたけどもね
それでも仕入れ担当であっても責任でしょ
荷物を棚に上げてくださいと言っても責任でしょ
それできるんだから雇っているし
その分給料もらってるし
我々はよく起こる問題
起こす問題なんですよ
決してどなたでも仕事の責任は重いとは思わないでください
重くないんです すごいシンプルなことを頼んでいるんです
この言い方悪い場合があります
上司が言い方が悪くて
人の能力はガクンと下げるように
もう一方的に喋る もう頭の悪い上司たちもいるんですね
だから上司になる資格のない人を上司にした上司が悪いんだからね
上司っていうのは やっぱり人の気分を良くして
みんなをちょっとおだててあげて
仕事をさせてもらいますよ
だから気分が良ければ仕事できるんですね
だから上司っていうのは本当は嫌な仕事なんです
みんなに自分から挨拶をして
みんなのいろいろ個人的なことでも聞いたり
問題を聞いてあげたり
悩みを聞いてあげたりする存在でなければいけませんね
日本では一方的に命令ばっかりするんですね
そうなってくると ちょっとあまり良くないんですね
はい それはそれで放っておいて
人を直せるのはね まあ上司を別な上司に入れ替えるということはね
まあできませんだからね
それは上の人やらなくちゃいけないし
私たちに頼まれる仕事っていうのは
自分にできるから頼んでいるのであって
まあこの仕事を責任重いとかねと思わないことなんで
答えは プレッシャーって何ですかね
やっぱりこれは責任が重いと思っちゃうとプレッシャーでしょうし
これ果たせないだろうと思っちゃうとプレッシャー出るしね
これぐらいの仕事俺はこれぐらいの時間ではできないだろうとかね
思っちゃうとプレッシャーでしょ
それは余計なこと何も思わない方がいいんです
今日 1 日の仕事分は今日 1 日でできなかったとしても構わないでしょうに
自分が怠けていなかったならば
しっかりとやったならば
まあ今お医者さんの顔を見せます
見えましたから たとえ新しいたとえが思い浮かんだんですけど
お医者さんというのは本当に責任重い仕事でしょうに
人の命ですからね 握っているのは
皆様の仕事は何だ？お医者さんの仕事から比較すると
お医者さんがちょっと手違いしたら人が死んじゃいますよ
で しかし お医者さんが手一杯医学的にできることを全部やりますけど
患者さんが死んじゃいますよ
時々治療に耐えられなくて死ぬ場合もあります
だから その例えで考えてください
普通の会社でも まあ今日 1 日
これぐらいやらなくちゃいけないと言われても
自分が精一杯やればいいんです
仕事残ったってもね そういうことで
私は自分の精一杯やりますと
自分の能力は尽くしますと
妄想はやめますと 仕事っていうのは単純であると
日本の総理になっても単純なんです
仕事は これすごいと思っちゃうんだから
ややこしくなるんです
で 総理大臣として何も能力もなかった総理大臣が一人いまして
皆様のこと知らないんだけど
私が日本にいる時代ではね
小泉さんというね 一番人気あるでしょ
それから国会議員としても資格はないと私は個人的に思う人がいて
日本では総理にした人の第1なんです
だったらどんなバカでも総理になりますよということにしたんです
私は 鳩山さんが失敗してますね
そんなに生ぬるくもうグニャグニャではできません
もうやっちゃえばいいんです
やるべきことを 特に日本人の話に乗っちゃえばね
何もできません はっきり言ってほしいんですよ
アメリカ軍隊は要りませんと
出ていけと  アメリカこそ我々は大事にしなくちゃいけないんだと
鳩山さん何するの？と
アメリカの政府の機嫌悪くなっちゃったんではないかと
これで日本とアメリカの友好関係
これになったんでは しかし
あの基地の移転は大反対だと
沖縄に置くことも大反対だと
日本中どこにでも入れるなよとまた言っちゃうし
こんなアホな人の話に乗る？総理ですから
自分好き勝手なことやればいいのに
ですごい好き勝手なことを
やっぱり気が強い人はそういう仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですね
独裁的で人の意見を聞かないならば
一番民主主義だと思われるんです
誰の意見も聞かなかったんでしょ
小泉さんは だから一番人気のあった民主主義者なんです
世界はバカバカらしい
矛盾ばっかりなんです
そういうことだから 人間ですから
我々はね 結局は もうどうしようもないんです
ですから 会社の場合でも
まあ自分の仕事はまあこんなのは簡単だと思ってやればいいんじゃないかなと思います
責任重いとは思わないことって最強です
ありがとうございます
次の質問です  50代の女性の方です
家庭のですね 実の母親と弟
自分の 3人で生活しています
私と母の感情の行き違いがよく起こります
言い合いをして お母さんが早くいなくなればいいのにとまで思ってしまう
怒りを観察しようとするのですが
怒りに巻き込まれてしまう
とても苦しんでいます
身近な人とうまく生活できる智慧はありませんか？という質問です
あの これはちょっと結構大きな間違いを犯していますね
自分が自分の実際の自分の母ですね
お母様ですね  自分のお母さんと
だから自分のお母さんでしょ
自分のお母さんを管理しようとしてるんですね
これは憲法違反です もう家族はもうお母さんとうまくいかないわ
父さんとうまくいかない
子供の言うこと聞かない
喧嘩するなんて そんなのどうったことはないんです
だってわがままを言う場所が家族ですからね
わがまま言い張ったりする場所が家族なんです
だから家族っていうのは無茶苦茶ですよ
だからそれが平和でいい家族だと思ってください
みんな言いたい放題のことを言っちゃうんだと
みんなそれぞれわがまま好き勝手に生きてるんだと
あ これでよかったなんですよ
誰かの話 真面目に聞いて
みんな一致団結してっていうのも
悪くてね 独裁組織じゃないんだからね
そういうわけで このいろいろそうわがまま言い張ったりすることはいいんだけど
母親を管理するということはもう憲法違反です
そこはちょっとなんか
あの 母は母なんですよ
年関係ないんです 自分が五十歳だと
私も五十歳でもう今孫がいるんですけどね
それはもうお母さんの前では成り立たないんです
お母さんが八十五歳だからね
そのギャップは埋めませんよ
このお母さんああしなさい
こうしなさいと言う方々は
いきなり随分年月を飛んでるんですね
これはありえないでしょ
だからそこで気持ち変えたらいいんです
やっぱりいつまでも母は母ですと
私にいちいちいちいち言う存在ですと
何やっても何か一言葉言う存在ですと
それでも一生 母が死ぬ瞬間まで
誰のことを一番心配するのかというと
自分のことを心配するんです
それは覚えておいてください
それからまあ お母さん何かあるとも
もうよくわかりましたけど
やりませんとね そんな調子で生きていればいいんです
お母さんが病院に行きたくないと言っちゃうとね
お母さんの気持ちは私も行きたくないんだけどね
でも連れて行きますよと
面倒くさいんだからとかね
そんな感じで相手の人権を守ってあげてください
人権の中でも母という人権っていうのはもう乗り越えられないんです
私たちは何やってもその人の作品なんですね
自分で一人で特許は取れません
私は私ですと だから誰でも子供でしょ
母と父の あの二人が特許を取ってるんです
だから こんな年になって私の両親はいないんだけど
年上の兄弟は一人ぐらいはいますけどね
私はやっぱり向こうは特許を取っているんだから
何でも反論はしません
何かあると聞いてるだけ
別に言ってることをそのままやるかやらないか
それは自分が自由だからわがままだからね
年上の兄弟が何かこれこれと言っても
まあよく聞いて でもね
私はね こういう風にやりたいんだけど
どうする？って まあいいよと言うんです
また逆に だからそこら辺で
この何て言いますか この我々にはこの侵害できない関係がありますね
それは侵害しないでください
それはもうどうしてもできない
たとえ自分の母が年取って痴呆ではなくて認知障害になっても
もうどうしようもないでしょうね
それでもあの母は娘のこと
息子のこと忘れているかもしれませんけど
我々は接するときは これはやっぱりまあ特許を取ってる母であるということだけ心に入れておいてください
こちらは特許を取ってますから
もうしょうがないと いうところで落ち着くと思います
はい  ありがとうございます
お時間の関係で 次最後の質問とさせていただきます
四十代の男性の方からのご質問です
私は今まで日本で生まれ育ってきて
海外へは旅行で行った程度ですが
どうしても日本という国が好きになれず
いずれはタイのようなアジア圏の国に移り住みたいと思っています
そう考えるのは逃げることで
何の問題の解決にもならないのでしょうか？という質問
あのね ちょっと行ってみたら
人間にはそういう気持ちは生まれますよ
それはごく自然なんです
お釈迦様もね 自分の人生の花開く場所に引っ越すことを教えているんです
これはもうしょうがないんです
例えばアメリカの大学やら研究所やらね
行ってみたら白人はほぼないんですね
ノーベル賞もそちらだけ取りますけど
研究してるのはインド人か中国人かでしょうに
ですから やっぱり自分の国では能力もあるし
すごい頭がいいし でも花が開けませんね
なので そちらに行って生活する
日本でも抜群に能力ある科学者の方々はアメリカに行ってますからね
だからノーベル賞も取ったりするでしょう
日本ではもうダメ もう叩かれます
そういうことだから この生まれた国を離れる
生まれた田舎を離れる
場所を離れるということは一向に構わないんです
地球上どこに住んだっても構わない
しかし ポイントがあります
自分の能力を発揮できて幸福になれるのか
周りの人々もそれでよかったと思うのかと
アフリカのどこかの国に行って
いるあるお医者さんのこと
テレビ番組で見ましたけど
外務省で医者として仕事していた人で
すごいむちゃくちゃ苦労もらったりして
あの国に行ったところでも
もう自分が医者ですけど
なんでもう普通の人に治療してはいけないのかと腹が立っちゃってね
仕事まで辞めちゃって
その国に住んで活動今やってるんですね
すごい厳しい あのもうテロもテロもいっぱいあるんですよ
頑張ってやってるんです
で 奥さんが子供二人がいて
もう大変で 奥さんも奥さんでも
あんた何か言ったらもうやるんだからね
まあしょうがないやと
奥さんがまた新しく学校の先生になって
子供を育てて お互い仲良く活動していますね
だから その国の人々もすごい喜んでいるし
役に立っているし 本人もしっかりといいことをやっているんだって
本当にいいことやってるんだからね
いいことやってるっていうこともあるし
こちらの家族の人であっても
まあそれなりにそっちは言いますからね
もう自慢できるし だからそういうことで花開けるならば
家族もバラバラでも構いませんよ
お父さんは別なところでお母さんが
お母さんが別なところへとかに
そんなに気にすることじゃないんだ
今質問した方々はちょっと調べ
なんて言いますか グラウンドリサーチしてないんですね
だからちょこちょこっと行ってみて
どうですかね この人間は
とかね 気に入られるのかないのかとかね
調べたらわかるでしょう
はい 終わりです  ありがとうございます
他にもたくさん質問いただいたんですが
ちょっと時間の関係で割愛させていただきます
それでは これから祝福の今日のコーナーに入りたいと思います
ナモタッサ バガトアラハトサンマサンブッダッサーサ
イティピソ パジャランサンマサンブッドー
ヴィッチャーチャーナサンパンノ
シュガトーローカヴィトーアンチャーロー
プリサダンナサーラーティーサッチャーデーワマヌッサーナムブッドーバガヴァーティー
スワッハートー パラッタダンモーサンティッティコーワターニコーエーバッシーコーモパナイコーパッチャッタンヴェーディタッポーヴィニュニーティー
ウパティパンノーバガラトーサーヴァササンコーウジュパティパンノーバガラ
トサーカサンゴナーヤパティカンノバガワトサーワタサンゴサーミーチパティカンノバガワトサーワタサンゴヤニダンチャッタニプリサユカーニアッキャプリサトゥンダラーテーサバガワトサーワタサンゴ
パーウネイヨパーウネイヨラッキネイヨアンダリダネイヨ
アンタラムトゥニャッキッタムローカッサーティ
エーテーナサッチャワンジェーナパートゥタンガタナッキャヤム
ヤーニダホーターニサマーガターニトゥンマーニワーヤーニバランダリンケー
サンベーヴァホータースマナーバワントゥ
ワトーピサッキャッジャスマントゥラーシラム
タスマーイホーターニサーメータサンベーメッタンタロータマヌッシアパチャーヤ
ディワーチャラントーチャランティエーハリッタスマーイティメラークラッパラッターヤム
キンキミッタミダワーランカーサンケースワーヤム
ラタナンパニータンマノサマッティラカーテーナ
イダンピプンテーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥパーヤンヴィラーガムアマタムパニータン
ヤタッジャターサッキャムニサマーリトーナテーナダンメーナサマンティティ
ティーダンピダンメーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥーヤン
ブッダセットーパリワンナイースティンサマーディターナンパリガンニャマーローサマーディナテーナカモーナキッチャティ
イダンピダンメーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
エープングラーアッキャサダンパサッダーチャッダーディレーターニユターニマンディー
エーラッキネイヤーシュタタッササーヴァカーエーテーシュディンナーニマープラダーニ
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
エーシュッパユンターマナサーダルレーナ
イッダーミノホーダナサーラナンビーテーパンティマンターマタミタイヤー
ダンダムダーニップディンデュンジャカーナーイ
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
ヤミッガキーローパパニッソーティヤーチャトゥンピワーテーヴィアサンパタンピヨータドゥママンサップリサンワラーミー
ヨーワイヤサッチャーミーアヴェッチャパッサティー
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
エーアウィヤサッチャーミーヴィバーヤンティーダンテーラパンジェーナシュテーシターニーケーチャーヴィテーホンティプッタッターターマテーパーワンアッタマンナキヤンティー
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
サーマヴァッササッサンサンパダーヤダヤーシュダンマジャミターンティー
サンガーイッテーチキンチダンチャシーラーマタムワーピヤラッティヒンチッチャーナウパターエー
イチャレッパムントータターヴィダーナーニヤバッポーカートゥン
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッチェーナスワッティロトゥ
キンチャー-...テーラワーダチェータサーヴァーバンポソーパッサマティッチャーダーヤ
アバンタターディッタパダッサルッター
イダンピサンケーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッテーナスヴァッティホトゥ
アーパムンペーアカーウッスィダンケーインマーナマーセーパラマスミンキンメー
タポーパマンダンマバーマテーサリーバーナダンミバーランミターヤ
イダンピブッテーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッテーナスヴァッティホトゥ
アローパナンニューマタローアーハーローアンタローダンマパランマテーサリーダンピブッテーラタナンパニータン
キーナンプーナーニマワンナティサンタワン
ヴィヤッタチッターヤティケーワーサンニンテーケーアティーヤーハリユッリンチャンターインバンティディーラーヤカーヤンパディーポー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータン
エーテーナサッテーナスヴァッティホトゥ
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニ
イドゥンマーニバーヤーニバーランタリッケー
カタガタンデーワナムサプージタム
ブッダンナマッサーマスヴァッティホトゥ
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニ
イドゥンマーニバーヤーニバーランタリッケー
カタガタンデーワナムサプージタム
ダンマムナマッサーマスヴァッティホトゥ
ヤーニイダブーターニサマーガターニ
イドゥンマーニバーヤーニバーランタリッケー
カタガタンデーワナムサプージタム
サンガムナマッサーマスヴァッティホトゥ
エーテーナサッチャワンジェーナ
ドゥッカウーパサミンチュテー
バーヤウーパサミンチュテー
エーテーナサッチャワンジェーナ
サークーパサミンチュテー
パーニヤマッタクサレーナ
イダンタムサンタムパタンアビサミッチャ
サッポージュチャスージュチャ
スワチョージャッサムトゥワナティマニ
サンチュッサコーチャ
スパラジョラッパキッチョーチャ
サッラウパルッジーサンティンリヨーチャニタポーチャ
ラッパラッポープーレーシュワー
ギッドーナチャグンダンサマチャレーチーシエータギッニューパレーウパデーリオン
スキノーワーケーリノーホンドゥ
サッベーサッサーバーイトゥスッキダンターエーケーチパーヌターミーナサーバーターヴァラーバーナセーサーディーガーバーレーナーンダアーマナジーナーラッサカー
ヌカトゥーナーヒッカーエーヴァラッビッターエーチャルーデーヴァサンティアミドゥーデーウーパーサンマヴェーシーラーン
サッベーサッターバーイトゥスッキダンター
タローアーニンデュンベターラーニマンニェカカッタチナンタンジービャーローサナパティラサンニャーナーニャナンニャッサドゥッカニッジェーヤーナーカーヤターニ
ヤンプッタアーユサーエーカブッタマヌラクケーランヴィサンパトゥテーシュルマナサンターヴァエーアパリマナン
ヴィンタンチャサンパロータスミンマナサンターヴァエーアパリマナン
プッタムアトーチャキリヤンチャアサンパーダンアヴェーランナサパンタンティッタンチャニティンノーワーサヤーノーワービャーダカッサヴィラタミッドーエータンサ
ミンアヴィッテーヤダンマメタンヴィアーランイダナーボロヴィッティンチャダンタランマシーラマーダッサデーナサンパンノーカーメーシュヴィニーヤデーヤンマリジャートゥダンマセイヤントゥナレーティーティー
エーテーナサッチャワンジェーナナッディテーホートゥサンバターエーテーナサッチャワンジェーナホートゥテージャヤマンガラン
エーテーナサッチャワンジェーナサンパローゴヴィナッサポーレーワンメーシュタンゲータンサマヤンパダマーサーヴァッディヤンヴィヤワティジェータワニーアナータミッティナッサラーラー
タンタコーパダマービックーアーアンテーシービッカホーティパダンテーティーテービックーパタコパッチャッソースンパダワーレーパダポジャブータプンバンビッカレーデーヴァー
sura サンガーモサンパンプルローアホーティ
タトゥービッカヴェーサッコーデーワーニンドーデーヴェターヴァティンセーアーマンテーシーサテーマーリサーデーマーナサンガーナカタナンブッパッジェーヤアヤ
ンワーチャンピタッタンワーローマハンソーワーマメータスミ
サマレーダジャッカンウルローケイヤータ
ママーニゴーラヤッダンウルローカヤタンヤンパヴィッサティパヤンワーチャンピタッタンワーローマハンソーワーソーパリーッサティーノーテーメーダラッカンウルローケイヤータ
マヤーパティッサデーヴァラージャッサダジャッカンウルローケイヤータ
マヤーパティッサリボーデーヴァラージャッサダジャッカンウルローカヤタンヤンパヴィッサティパヤンワーチャンピタッタンワーローマハンソーワーソーパリーッサティー
ノーテーマヤーパティッサデーヴァラージャッサダジャッダンウルローケイヤータ
アタヴァルナッサデーヴァラージャッサダジャッダンウルローケイヤータ
ヴァルナッサリボーデーヴァラージャッサダジャッダンウルローカヤタンヤンパヴィッサティパヤンワーチャンピタッタンワーローマハンソーワーソーパリーッサティー
ノーテーヴァルナッサデーヴァラージャッサダジャッダンウルローケイヤータ
アハリサーッサデーヴァラージャッサダジャッダンウルローケイヤータ
アリサーッサ-...
サーカサンボージュパティバンノーバガヴァトーサーカサンボーニャーヤパティバンノーバガヴァトーサーカサンボーサーミージパティバンノーバガヴァトーサーカサ
ンボーヤンヤンチャンダリトゥリサユバーニヤッタトゥリサトゥンガラエーサバガヴァトーサーカサンボーアーブネイヨーカーブネイヨーダッキーネイヨーアンジャリ
パラニヨーアヌッタラムトゥンヤンウェッタンローカッサラーティサンターニボービッカヴェーアヌッサラタンヤンパヴィッサティパヤンマーチャンビラッタムワローマ
ハンソーワーソーパリーッサーティタングキッサラエトゥーアラータコービッカヴェーアラハンサッマサンブッドーヴィタラーゴーヴィタトーローヴィタノーアビルワッ
チャンティアナートラーシヤパラエーティタマボージャパダマーヤダンヴァルヴァーサゴーアッパサンヘパジャローチャサンターランニールーパムーレーヴァーシュンヤーカーレーヴァビッカ
ノー
アヌッサレータサンブッダンパヤントゥンマアガノーシラーノージェブッダンサレイヤータローカジェッタンマーラサハンアガナンマンサレイヤータニーヤニカンシュデ
シタンノージェダンマンサレイヤータニーヤニカンシュデシタンアタサンガンサレイヤータプンヤッケダンマヌッタランゲーワンブッダンサランターダンマンサンガンチ
ャビッカローパナンマーチャンビタッタンワローマハンソーナエッサジーデーナサッチャワンデー
ナソ
ティデーホトゥサンパラエーテーナサッチャワンデーナホトゥテーナヤマンガエーテーナサッチャワンデーナサッパローボーウィナッサトゥタンナンカロマーディーロー
メランカロマーヤトーサラナンカロローパリトーディーパンカロジュティンダロープンダンニョージャナスワモッコーマンガローブディササポーシュマノシュマノーデ
ィーローデーワトーアビヴァンダノーショービトーグナサンパンノーアノーマジャシーアヌッタモーパドゥノーローカパッジョトーナーラローワラサーリパドゥヌンタロ
ーサッダサーロースメドーランガドゥッカローシュジャトーサッパトーカンポーヴィヤダッシーナラーサポーアッタダッシーカールニコーダンナダッシータモーナトー
シッダッコーワサモーローケーティッソーワラタサンワロープッソーワラタサンブッンドーヴィパッシーチャアノーパモーシケーサンバイトーサッダーヴェッサポーシュ
カターヤトーガクサンドーサッダラーローホウナアグマノーアーナンダホーカッサポーシーサンパンノーローパノーサッキャプンガホーテーサンサンテーナシーレーナ
カンティメッタパレーナチャーテーピタンナムラッカンツーアーローゲーナスケーナチャーディーババトゥサッバマンガナムラッカンツーサッバデーワターサッバプッ
ダーヌバーレーナサラーソッティーバワントゥテーババトゥサッバマンガランラッカンツーサッバデーワターサッバダンマヌバーレーナサラーソッティーバワントゥテー
ババトゥサッバマンガランラッカンツーサッバデーワターサッバサンターヌバーレーナサラーソッティーバワントゥテーアーカーサッダージャトゥンマンターデーワー
ナーラーマインディカプンヤンタンマヌモーディッバーチランラッカントゥローカサーサナアーカーサッダージャトゥンマンター
..
.ヴァッカントゥ デーサ ダンマカ サッチャーチ ウッマッダ デーヴァーナーガ マヒッティカ プンニャンタン
アンモティッパ チラッンヴァッカントゥ ブンタラ
デーヴォ ヴァッサスプパーレーナ サッサ サンパッティ ホーチュ チャ ピートー パトゥローポチャ ラージャン パトゥダンミネコ
サーガティサーガティサーガティ
え それでは  最後に皆さんでの今日の皆さんで半日近くえー
努めた...今日のお話を聞いたりして
得た功徳を全部に回すと唱えたいと思います
えっと 回向の文という文書をえー
おぶってらっしゃる すみません
ちょっとあのー パソコン切り替えてください
えーと パソコンの方は Windows の方に切り替えてもらえますか
じゃあすいません 覚えてる方いましたので
イスマーの御題回向の文を唱えて
皆さんの功徳を一切の生に回向します
では 皆さん合掌して一緒に唱えてください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝礼し
戒律の義 因の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖国 父母 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サーガティサーガティサーガティ
え それでは皆様 長い時間どうもありがとうございました
一番最後にですね あのー
テーラワーダ仏教協会の会長のコニシンの方から
あのー 締めの挨拶をいただきたいと思います